Brasilia, el país está políticamente
polarizado
uno secretó Paraná y es y Lula oscuro solo
en su congreso prometí unirme a la a a
Brasilia sufre sustos a kilómetros de
seguidores como uno para estafarlo cuando
incluido el sector arraigado en la guerra si
todos con nosotros en este lugar
santo todos a todos y
a todo terrorismo que pretenda Oi
y en el terrorismo el fascismo eso es lo que
Estar mirando a su alrededor porque
presupuesta o no inhibida azulada porque la
ser algo muy
importante que ella sea inteligencia
investiga todos los orcassos aquí en
Finanzas Dom siendo las armas estas
importante
hay polarización
A qué se parece
dormir
esto es un poco artificial porque no lo es
¿Quién es realmente fascista si los apostadores?
revolucionario
de Lula del PT
queriendo aparecer
noticias falsas noticias falsas y esas cosas
Entonces me parece que cuando Lula
gobernador
para agregar ese equipo y obtener un
recuperación económica y estará lista
por qué
ya va a evolucionar allí políticas
de reparto de 80 porque lograron
enmienda constitucional adecuada que permita
el precio del cráneo
ya lo intento
marinero pero luego para enviar cuando
esta cosa
es eso
Me parece que Lavinia está lista.
y si hay en mi calle
quien abrazó
porque estaba en la mala situación y creo
sobre lo que estaba viendo cuando la situación del
merhur
ni siquiera ligaron con bolsonaro entonces tu
me parece que en la mejora o en minoría
Peri Grosso y sigue este en Brasil
eder importante
Por lo que me parece, ella está ahí.
polarización del gran yo fui Cirilo
en los últimos años disminuirá mucho
tanto por ahí
estilo
es concejal y no hay manera de que no pueda serlo
¿Por qué las minorías también lo son?
por favor dale el diccionario que son hermanos
por ejemplo
Si este texto es un tema que siempre he sido
cuando Lula era presidente durante
La primera vez también fue un tema como
imba na septar quemar quemar pasar
Lula pulsa a un general retirado
Ministerio que pertenecía a este guardia Entonces
serás un humano allí con el
militar para ídolos
que han ocupado desde entonces por temor a la destrucción de
bolsonaro empeoró después como
bolsonaro operado
muchos ministerios
multiplicana soy profesora
Ay, qué
disminuir la presencia militar y nuestra
epitágora que los militares dieron opinión
política en cada momento como este año en
situación
Lacesto dura mucho como tú y yo.
parece que no sera un problema
seriamente para disminuir
para cambiar líderes de Los militares
por el otro, un calentamiento más democrático
y bruno
porque cuando Lula era presidente
unas militares que se casaron con ella toda
haciendo que desaparecieran por ejemplo
entonces usted
Los pases en el ejército crecieron dentro de ella.
Fuerzas Armadas